ERIC BIDELMAN:
Welcome, everyone.
I'm Eric Bidelman.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google,
working in the Polymer
team and Web Components.
Web Components are a fundamental
shift in web development.
They're going to
change everything.
They're the future
of web development,
and we're thrilled
that all of you
are here today helping out
and learning about them.
Welcome to Polytechnic.
Throughout the
month of November,
we've partnered with
hundreds of developer groups
around the world that host
similar events like this one.
We're excited to see what
all you guys are going
to build today on top
of Web Components.
So for all of you that
are new to Polymer,
we actually started the
project over two years ago
as an OpenSource project,
and we started it
for a couple of really
important reasons.
First, it was to gain
valuable experience
and provide feedback to
the standards bodies.
This has been really
important to kind of evolve
the specs over time.
The four main specs-- HTML
imports, custom elements,
Shadow DOM, and
templates-- these
have all improved over
the last four years,
largely thanks to
the Polymer teams'
involvement of these projects.
The second thing
we wanted to do,
we wanted to create a
well-lit path for developers.
This includes building a set of
polyfills so you the developer
can use Web Components
today in browsers
that don't support
the Native APIs.
We wanted to make
developers more productive.
I like writing less code,
and I'm sure you do too.
Web Components do a whole lot
for web developer ergonomics.
They allow you to build
reusable, declarative,
interoperable, custom elements.
And of course, we're starting
a new ecosystem here,
an entirely new ecosystem
of Web Components.
So we wanted at the
Polymer team to seed
the community with a
valuable set of rich,
visual, and non-visual
custom elements,
show the power of
these technologies.
Most recently too, we
talked about material design
at Google I/O. Polymer has
a set of paper elements
that you can use to achieve
material design in your apps.
So with Android
and Web, now we can
create the same app that looks
and feels exactly the same.
So if you're new to
Polymer, welcome.
You're going to
learn a lot today.
If you've already tried
it, help someone else out.
Upload your stuff to GitHub.
Create something
reusable, something new.
We'd love your feedback,
so please, please
file bugs if you find
anything that's amiss.
So thanks a lot.
Have a lot of fun,
enjoy the schwag,
and go componentize the web.